the nfl is gay it is
super duper gay it is liberace level
gay and that is not my opinion well
that is my opinion actually but it uh
what i'm saying is it's not my opinion
uh it is my opinion because the nfl
says that it is true and i'm not i'm not
saying that the nfl
is lame or stupid or well i actually am
saying that the nfl is lame and stupid
but i'm not i'm not using the word gay
to mean lame and stupid like people do
in middle school or anything like that
i'm set i just i want to be very clear i
am saying the nfl is gay
in the narrow sense of men who are
sexually attracted
to men because that's what the national
football
league tells me that it is and not to be
outdone
kermit the frog is gay as well and and a
british man is now a korean
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
two days left in pride month i don't
know that i can keep up
i don't i don't know what is kermit the
nfl
the brits becoming koreans my favorite
comment yesterday
from the enforcer who says i'm so glad
that my kids are back in school
they were falling behind in their
afro-indigenous non-binary transsexual
studies
yes well no that's a big fear it's a big
fear because you know you get about
three years of that
discipline in school now this actually
is a very good point that you're making
which is
many conservatives pointed out it's
cruel to keep kids out of school and
away from their friends and sports and
it's true that it's bad to keep kids
away from their friends and their sports
and everything
but keeping them out of those schools
actually may be
a benefit to them that might be the
silver lining in the storm cloud of the
coronavirus lockdowns
always trying to look for a silver
lining well you know what
even in our crazy chaotic world here's
one silver lining you can know who's on
your doorstep
with a ring there are a thousand reasons
why you want to protect your home for me
there's one reason in particular cute
little june my five-month-old baby he's
so cute
i want to make sure that no one comes to
do him harm
maybe that's a burglar maybe no maybe
not just do him hard maybe there's a
delivery guy okay then i'll open the
door
maybe it's my in-laws i don't know and
that they love
you know they love him they want to see
him but it might be i just i just want
to know who's outside the door okay is
that so much to ask
i can do that with ring i can see and
speak
to whoever is on my doorstep i can keep
an eye on every corner of my home with
ring so simple so affordable makes a
great housewarming gift because
especially because it's not very
expensive
you can see and speak whether you are in
your home
at your office or on the other side of
the world all from a simple app
go do it you'll feel like you're in the
jetsons start protecting your home today
with ring alarm go to ring.com
knowles kennedy wles get your ring alarm
security kit today
you can build the system that's right
for your home and have it up and running
in minutes
ring dot com slash knowles wlas that is
ring.com
knowles i've said it for years i've said
it for years that football is gay and i
know that it's
that seems ambiguous because i could be
referring to soccer
but i also i could be referring to the
nfl and people thought i was
being insulting they thought that i was
i'm not i'm trying to be very
specific and the nfl has just proven me
right
yet again nfl coming out with a very
important commercial
describing itself identifying itself
as gay football is
gay they're right football is lesbian
football is beautiful
football is queer exciting transgender
power bisexual strong freedom
american accepting everything football
is everything
and football is for everyone the nfl
and then at the end here it says nfl
proudly supports trevor project
lgbt youth with at least one accepting
adult have 40 percent lower risk of
attempting suicide go to
thetrevorproject.org
okay first of all
this tactic here at the end
is the tactic of an abusive husband
because what they're saying is
if you do not get on board with pride
month and you do not say that
football is gay and everything is gay
and football is everything
if you do not get on board with that
then you are killing gay people
that's the implication they're saying
that if you do not
get totally on board with pride month
then you are impelling people to kill
themselves
nobody is suggest nobody that i have
ever met
is suggesting that we should be cruel to
people who especially to young people
who have unusual sexual desires
that we should ostracize them that we
should be you know
vicious and mean and nobody is saying
that
but what what this commercial is saying
at the very end here it's almost like a
side point
you're saying if you do not 100 give in
to a very left-wing vision
of sex that includes transgender if you
won't
trans the kids i'm going to kill myself
you're going to make me kill myself why
do you make me do this i love you so
much
this is the the language and the
rhetoric of an abuser
and the left is abusing this country and
using all the same manipulative tactics
but zoom out a little bit football
is gay lesbian proud strong bisexual
transgender
the list goes on and on and on football
is everything
football is not everything
football cannot be everything
nothing can be everything football for
instance is not baseball
football is not an omelette football is
not the number 15.
and this this uh error that the left is
making
is to erase all distinctions between
everything
you see this obviously in the case of
transgenderism the distinction between
man and woman
you see this obviously in the case of
the redefinition of marriage the
distinction between marriage and
not marriage you see this obviously in
the case of oh gosh i don't know
local state and federal government
that's all blurring together you see
this
obviously in the case of the various
institutions of our government
the various branches of power even the
institutions outside of our government
all kind of blurring together the line
between big tech and the universities
and the government all a little blurry
the left is blurring
all these sorts of distinctions and they
do it with their language
which by the way relates to my book
speechless which is now available for
order it's doing very well in the orders
thank you very much for helping me stick
a finger
at the eye of the uh left wing best
seller list it'd be really fun if we
could
manage to do that we'll see what happens
this is what they want to do they want
to blur the distinction
between all of these things but words
this is why the left focuses on language
so much
words discriminate that is what they do
the very purpose of words is to
distinguish
one thing from another but the nfl says
no
everything is everything there's no
distinction between anything they're
doing it with critical race theory
they're retreating into this position of
nominalism they're saying what is
critical race theory
it's nothing what does that word even
mean words don't mean anything
it's all kind of the same man
come on have a puff that's that is the
error here this is so much
so far beyond the issue of gay lesbian
transgender it's about everything but
not to be outdone
kermit the frog does not want to
to be left behind in the wok cloud of
dust by the nfl
so kermit the frog also doing his part
to promote pride month yeah ig i am so
sorry to interrupt hi kermit what's up
oh well uh you see i have a bit of a a
style
question and you you have such
impeccable
style i thought i'd come to you you're
asking me
well you certainly know how to flatter a
girl
you see i can't decide what to wear for
my big number
i thought maybe you could help me oh i'd
love to kerm oh good
but why don't you just ask miss piggy oh
um
well i i did but uh i am not too
crazy about her choices uh all right
take a look at this
there's this one whoa wicked wiki what
is that
okay you for those who were only
listening and not
seeing that you're very lucky
congratulations maybe i'll just start
listening to this show myself
uh there was a giant drag queen with big
purple hair wearing a dress
and it though it was it's just very very
creepy
to have this on children's programming
but of course the left has to have this
on children's programming of course the
trans
issue has to go to the kids there are
three positions on this i think
there is the left wing position which is
trans everybody including the kids
then there is the kind of squishy
liberal position center right center
left
which is well if adults want to mutilate
their bodies they should absolutely be
allowed to do that
but we shouldn't trans the kids and then
there's the conservative position which
is that this is
wrong men are not women there is such a
thing as truth there is such a thing as
goodness and
we should prefer those things to
falsehood and not goodness and so
no no one should be allowed to mutilate
perfectly healthy body parts
because of a delusion that they have and
people are
unwilling sometimes on the squishy right
to say that sort of thing
but the problem with the squishy
position here the adults can do it but
the kids can't
is that either a man can become a woman
or he can't
and if a man can become a woman then it
actually would be better to do that
before puberty sets in
right that's the le that is the
left-wing argument on it and it makes
sense if you accept the premise that a
man can become a woman
so certainly you and even beyond that
beyond the question of consent if we're
saying that it's
good for a man to become a woman if he
feels that he is a woman
then this question of consent goes away
the issue with transiting the kids the
squishy people believe is that kids
can't consent
but but we're already establishing that
it is a good thing
for men who think they're women to
become women and so children have
decisions made for them for their for
their best
on on their behalf by their parents all
the time so there's no reason that
transiting the kids wouldn't be one of
them
you can't if you stand in the middle of
the road especially on an issue like
this
you are going to get hit by a bus and
the left pushes the stuff in front of
kids
in no small part because kids brains are
squishy kind of like those other
republicans
kids brains are are very malleable
kids brains are easily influenced by
what they see particularly what they see
on television if anyone who's ever put a
kid in front of a tv knows their brains
just turn off they start drooling they
start looking
they quiet down which is very convenient
so the left
has to push this stuff on kids through
the schools through the mainstream media
through these television shows all over
the place
and the conservatives are standing up
against it but if we don't get some of
those people on the center right to come
with us as well
we're just not going to have the
political power to stop it anyone
with two brain cells and a modicum of
common sense can look at this and say
this is ghastly
get this away from the kids
unfortunately even the conservatives of
the supreme court
do not appear to have the basic common
sense that says a man shouldn't go into
the ladies room
yesterday we got word from the supreme
court
that they are turning down the
opportunity to reverse a lower court
ruling
that forces a school to let men
little little boys you know students who
are men into the women's room
it's a little bit complicated because
the court didn't rule on the case they
refused to hear the case which upholds
the lower court ruling
which says that there is a
constitutional right for dudes to go
into the women's room the court declined
to hear the case of gavin grimm
who is a virginia female student who
identifies as a boy so this girl
who is pretending to be a boy who sued
the gloucester county school board
for stating that restrooms were limited
to the corresponding biological
genders
thank goodness we got amy barrett on the
court oh thank goodness we got kavanaugh
on the court
by the way thank goodness we have
gorsuch on the court gorsuch has been
one of the worst people on these issues
all of these people told me they were
originalists
amy barrett when she was up for the
position said she was an originalist
neil gorsuch said he was an originalist
thankfully thomas and alito held the
line but they dissented
it didn't it didn't do very much the
others
were not so if originalism means
that there is a constitutional right for
boys to use the girls room
i'm not sure i assume the founding
fathers and the framers are rolling over
in their graves at that suggestion
but if that's what originalism means
i guess i'm not an originalist i always
thought i was kind of an originalist
but i i don't think i am if originalism
means pretending
that the constitution guarantees a man's
right
to go do what he wants to do in the
women's room
that's obviously not true why why did
the court punt on this case
i don't think i don't think that amy
barrett and kavanaugh and
roberts is a lost cause and gorsuch i
don't think that they punted
necessarily because of their deeply
principled position
i suspect they punted because of their
cowardice
i suspect they punted because this is a
very tricky issue
and it's unpopular and so they just
don't want to deal with it they don't
want their hands on it and
and it actually has the further effect
of now enshrining this is law without
anyone passing a law for it
this is how the liberal establishment
holds power
okay when the liberal establishment
wants to defend something that is very
very unpopular that you know
that people are going to come out and
and vote against if it's put up to a
vote
they just have the court do it for them
because the court is not accountable to
the people and they'll give
their sort of protection now now the
court will get good coverage in the
media
they'll have the institutions backing
them up but this is what the liberal
establishment does
they rely on the court to to do their
dirty work
they did the same with same-sex marriage
yeah the idea of redefining marriage was
deeply deeply unpopular
when it was put on the ballot in
california of all places
it was shot down and it was in
particular unpopular among
a core constituency of the democratic
party which would be black voters
so because the liberal establishment
which wanted to redefine marriage
because they they had been pushing this
through
television shows like will and grace
they had been pushing this through the
curricula
they had been pushing this through the
courts though it hadn't gone very far
they had been trying to do it through
the electoral means but that didn't work
so because it
wasn't working they just went in and had
the romantic poet anthony kennedy and
the supreme court
redefined marriage they did this with
abortion abortion
some states were legalizing at other
states we're pushing back against it
right now there's no question about it
if the if it were put up to a vote if
this were not
if the supreme court had not invented
the fictional constitutional right to
abortion there is no question
that a huge number of states in this
country would outlaw abortion actually
a lot of states have a provision now in
their law
that if roe v wade is overturned
abortion is automatically criminalized
in the state so
they did that the court just had to do
it on behalf of the liberal
establishment
and the same thing is true of
affirmative action also known as
anti-white racism
and and often anti-asian racism
that that policy is very unpopular that
people would vote against that
i suspect people of all races would vote
against that
but certainly whites and asians who are
being now legally discriminated against
would vote against that
and so the court has to defend it they
keep defending it and very
often like sandra day o'connor when she
was on the court they will even admit
this is obviously unconstitutional this
is obviously wrong
but to rectify past wrongs we're just
going to have this policy for
for a little bit longer it's just a
temporary policy and so they'll argue
for that and then the temporary policy
never goes away very unpopular stuff now
sometimes what the liberal establishment
is
pushing is so deeply unpopular
that they have to reverse course and
when they reverse course they just blame
republicans
for the policy in the first place
nowhere is this clearer than on defund
the police
the democrats leading elected democrats
have been calling now for a year
at least to defund the police and
when when squishier democrats have tried
to
pull back from that a little bit you'll
have aoc and the others come out and say
no no defund the police means defund the
police it means taking away their money
and abolishing the police departments so
this this uh policy doesn't play very
well in peoria
turns out that when you've got crime
spikes around the country when first of
all when left-wing terrorists burn your
country down for a year
and then there are crime spikes
afterwards 50 up in in shooting and
murders in chicago for instance
then all of a sudden the democrats say
gosh this isn't looking very good
so jen saki white house spokesman i kid
you not
just blamed republicans for defunding
the police
the president did mention that the
american rescue plan the
state and local funding something that
was supported by the president a lot of
democrats who
supported and voted for the bill could
help ensure
local cops were kept on the beat in
communities across the country
as you know didn't receive a single
republican vote that funding has been
used to keep
cops on the beat but at the time that
was sold as these local police
departments might have a pandemic
related budget shortfall not we need to
keep cops on the beat because there's
prime weight
i think that any local department would
argue that
keeping cops on the beat to keep
communities safe when they had to
because of budget shortfalls
fire police is is something that helps
them address
crime in their local communities local
communities the white house's argument
was
the american rescue plan is going to be
1400 checks it's going to be
vaccines vaccinators it's going to put
us on the path
to feeding the virus not it did those
things as well
it was a pretty good bill and piece of
legislation it was really good and if
you
if you don't vote for this one
particular funding bill where we just
give a bunch of money from the federal
government to these local governments
aren't you kind of defunding the police
uh no we're not you guys voted
explicitly to defund the police and we
opposed you when you did that
and now you're just pretending that if
we don't don't give some more stimulus
cheese to the local governments
that we're that we're defunding the
police no the policies were made
by these democrats now you're pretending
any funding for state
well it could have been used to defund
the police yeah okay i don't think so
they can't run away forever from the
conclusions
of their crazy policies my favorite
example it's not my favorite it's
actually a very sad example
but it's the clearest one in a long time
it's a
a british-born influencer
isn't it he's a social media guy who
just went
viral after completing his 18th
plastic surgery to look like a member of
the korean pop band
bts this man now
his name is ali london he also uses
plural pronouns
that's like the 17th strangest thing
about this story
he now identifies as
korean and he he shared his his new
self-identity journey
on social media i identify as korean
that's just my culture that's my home
country
that's exactly how i look now um
and i also identify as jimmy and that's
my career name but uh
not only that i just i know it's a
little bit confusing for some people
nobody's ever come out as jimin or
korean but um
this is something that you guys know if
you've followed my journey for the last
eight years i've really struggled with
identity issues
he's really struggled with identity
issues and now he's korean
some people are saying he's just doing
this for attention well i guess he's he
does everything for attention because
he's a social media influencer
but he's clearly got got something going
on here in his head he's had 18
surgeries to do this
and people are really upset on the left
about this and people are really
befuddled on the right about this
but the fact is this british dude
identifying as korean
makes much more sense than
transgenderism
it is much more believable that a white
guy
can become a korean guy than that any
kind of guy
can become any kind of woman because
race
is much less important to identity
than sex the fundamental distinction
among people is sex
the sexes are complementary they
together
form the fundamental political unit the
family they got different potty boards
to do different things and together they
make babies
the races have differences there's no
question
much less distinct much less important
and the left is very upset about this
because they've identified racism as the
as the worst possible sin they've kind
of redefined all sin as just
racism and especially if a white person
does anything to
appropriate a culture of another right
if if a white person
enjoys the culture of other people
that's called appropriation
if a white person doesn't care about the
culture of other people that's called
erasure so the white guy can't do
anything right
anything he does with regard to race or
culture is considered wrong and evil and
bigoted
but this makes much more sense now of
course the guy
is not really korean and of course the
man who thinks he's a woman is not
really a woman
but if you accept the logic of
transgenderism you you certainly must
accept that this guy is korean he's
obviously got identity issues we've all
got identity issues these days
this is i think because of the deeply
religious confusion of our society and
the question of what human nature really
is
but that question of who are we is is
now being accelerated
by the courts by the establishment which
is buying into these delusions
you know there's one guy in the court
who's standing firm
that would be clarence thomas and
there's a great great movie about
clarence thomas called created equal you
know
unfortunately amazon does not want you
to hear the story of clarence thomas
created equal was up there on amazon and
then amazon just took it off
during during black history month of all
things so daily wire decided you know we
think people should should be able to
see this movie
so we've got it streaming right now at
dailywire.com
subscribe head on over get 20 off your
new membership with code
justice and while you're at it you can
go order my book speechless controlling
words controlling lines available
everywhere right now you can get it at
your local bookstore
at barnes noble at amazon i think you
can still get
a signed first edition at premier
collectibles though they did sell out of
the first run
so if you order it now i think you will
still get it um
but you got to order it now also you can
get the kindle edition if you want to
read it right away maybe get multiple
editions
we get the audible get get all of them
head on over to go get speechless today
we'll be right back with a lot more
the liberal regime which does not
operate like we thought it did
you know it does not operate like they
told us i am a bill up on capitol hill
and
like they taught us when they used to
teach civics the regime operates a
little bit differently
the administrative government the
agencies that are unaccountable to
anyone
control a huge portion of political
power in this country in
tandem with of course the other
institutions the universities
big tech woke corporations
the media all sorts of things well now
we've we've got a report
from tucker carlson that he has
definitive proof that the nsa
once known as no such agency national
security agency
is spying on him but it's not just
political protesters the government is
spying on yesterday we heard from a
whistleblower within the u.s government
who reached out to warn us at the nsa
the national security agency
is monitoring our electronic
communications and is planning to leak
them in an attempt to take this show off
the air
now that's a shocking claim and
ordinarily we'd be skeptical of it is
illegal for the nsa to spy on american
citizens it's a crime
it's not a third world country things
like that should not happen in america
but unfortunately they do happen and in
this case they did happen
the whistleblower who was in a position
to know
repeated back to us information about a
story that we are working on
that could have only come directly from
my texts and emails
there's no other possible source for
that information
period the nsa captured that information
without our knowledge and did it for
political reasons
the biden administration is spying on us
we have confirmed that i have no reason
not to believe
tucker here a lot of people are
skeptical of tucker's claim why would
you be
first of all he's a pretty straight
shooter guy is a straight shooter when
especially when it comes to people on
television
he's one of the best if not the best
and is your claim that the nsa wouldn't
do this sort of thing they already do
they're spying on everybody they are
intercepting virtually all the data that
are going around the internet in the
united states
and in we know in many cases the
intelligence community
has been weaponized against opponents of
the dominant liberal regime
this happened in 2016. do you remember
the fbi
was was weaponized to spy on the trump
campaign
and they never let up the intelligence
community community kept going after
donald trump
for the entirety of his presidency they
tried to get him on this they tried to
get him on that they tried to get him on
russia they tried to get him on ukraine
russian ukraine are at war with one
another but somehow trump was colluding
with both
they try to get him on anything and
they'll use any tactic to do it
we've had reports out during the obama
administration
that the agencies were spying on other
journalists other journalists at
conservative outlets
you know that the irs was weaponized
against conservatives during the tea
party movement
this happens all the time
the conspiracy theory is that somehow
this whistleblower got tucker carlson's
text
through some other means of course it's
so obvious
unless tucker is just completely
fabricating the whole episode which i
don't i don't think that he is
then this should worry everyone and
there's a kind of irony here because do
you remember this this is actually i
think emblematic of the broader shift in
politics
during the early 2000s during the bush
years
republicans were the defenders of the
national security state
republicans were defenders of the
intelligence community
gone back and forth over the years who's
defending the cia who's defending the
fbi
is it republicans is it democrats but
now i think it is pretty clear
it's it's obvious the
republicans the conservatives are
treated as dissidents
in the liberal regime they are if you
go out and burn down a city on behalf
of the left you will be led off the hook
in manhattan and in the bronx the
majority
of blm rioters and looters
had their charges dismissed and then
most of the rest of them
had their charges pled down to offenses
like trespassing which don't carry any
jail time
meanwhile if you put on a horn helmet
and go dance around on nancy pelosi's
desk and maybe take her lectern
you will rot in prison for years you
will be hunted down by the feds
you will be dragged in front of very
serious prosecutors people who prosecute
terrorism
and you will rot in prison because the
left burning down the country even
though they killed many more people
even though they caused far more damage
even though they threatened more
government buildings
and certainly way more private
businesses
they are ideologically aligned with the
regime
and the right wingers are not and the
people in the horn helmets or whatever
and dancing on the desk are not
so there's going to be a different
standard here so it's just very strange
for conservatives to be defending the
national security state
unless as we've said for a long time
they're not really conservatives they're
kind of court jesters
in the kingdom of liberalism their job
is to
give the appearance of opposition to the
liberal establishment
but really ultimately to lose when push
comes to shove their job is to lose with
dignity they don't have any dignity when
they do it but that's
that's their job i think that's what
we're seeing
so much of the jockeying right now on
the right
what is the right what is conservatism
what is our view on
immigration what is our view on trade
what is our view on manufacturing
what is our view on the country on what
is our view on
anything basically so much of that
jockeying is between people
who want to play along with the
establishment and lose but be you know
basically
taken care of and people who want to
push back and who want to win
you know i thought there was a little
hope yesterday for about
i don't know four or five hours there
was some hope yesterday
that maybe some
left-wingers are going to face some
consequences
from some of the dominant institutions
because youtube banned
an organization called right wing watch
right wing watch is a leftist operative
group
that exists to get me fired and ben
fired and all basically everybody
everybody on the right and it kind of
like media matters
they go out they watch a lot of
conservative shows then they post clips
and they try to get us all fired
so youtube banned their channel and i
thought huh
that's pretty good that's pretty good
stuff
and it raised this other point which is
the thesis of my book
which is that some people on the left
were criticizing the republicans who
were happy about this
they said well hold on you're for cancel
culture when work
when you're canceling your enemies and
your opponents
but you're against cancel culture when
they're canceling you yes that's right
you got it you nailed it i'm glad you
finally heard me you must have read my
book
yes i strongly strongly
support cancelling certain people and
ideas
i like william f buckley jr like
virtually every conservative in the
country until about five minutes ago
strongly support standards and taboos
and ostracizing certain people and ideas
because i do think we should by by
definition a society has to agree on
some things
i was bill buckley launched the
conservative movement on that idea with
with
god and man at yale and after that with
a book defending joe mccarthy for
goodness sakes
yes that's a good thing but i knew
i knew i looked at that i said oh they
banned right wing watch
it's not going to last it's just not
gonna last it was must have been an
accident and it was
the reason they banned right-wing watch
is because right wing watch posts videos
of conservatives
so youtube has already reinstated their
channel and youtube basically said i'm
so sorry
our algorithm caught a bunch of
right-wingers doing things
so we tried to ban all of them but we
did so we didn't know
if we had known that you were posting
them ironically to try to get those
people fired
obviously we would have we would have
left the channel up
if only now you know there are plenty of
radical radical leftists on youtube
who see many heinous vile terrible
things
and they generally speaking don't have
their channels taken down
but if a conservative goes on and says
anything from the vile and the heinous
and the kooky to
just perfectly ordinary mainstream
things they will will very often
face consequences and speaking
of the viral videos of the libs
there's a video i have i wish i didn't
have to
play this this video was going it was
going around tik tok
and i thought in a month that is already
full of a lot of really weird videos
where you've got frogs talking to men
who are identifying as women and you've
got the nfl
identifying as gay and transgender and
you've got british people
identifying as koreans i thought i must
have seen it all right
but i hadn't because some
lib guy decided to do a little dance and
do a little song number
about how he's waxed and waxed
but still wearing a mask
[Music]
says
[Music]
it goes on you know you got to give the
guy credit it's actually kind of a
catchy tune compared to a lot of these
but i actually i actually as
cringe-inducing as the video is
i appreciate the honesty because what
this guy's admitting
is that the mask is not it's what i've
been saying from the very beginning
the mask is not primarily a scientific
or medical tool
it is primarily a political symbol he's
saying he's waxed
faxed wearing slacks and when he goes
outside he still wears a mask
because he doesn't want to be confused
with a trump supporter
he's saying the cdc tells me that i
don't need the mask the mask doesn't do
anything
but i'm not wearing the mask because it
does anything i suspect a great many
people were not wearing the mask because
it actually did anything
they're wearing the mask because it's a
political symbol to show you that you
are a good person
you know recently some stores have not
been able to keep it up people are just
going to take the masks off
so they put up signs they save it if you
are vaccinated
then you do not need to wear a mask so
when you go into stores now
you'll see some people are wearing masks
some people are not and the irony of
course is
that every single person who is not
wearing a mask
is unvaccinated and every single person
without much exaggeration every single
person who is wearing a mask
is vaccinated this is i i've overheard
people saying this
i know many people are going to the
stores this
is a political distinction because the
the neurotics who really were afraid of
the wuflu from the very beginning
are of course going to continue wearing
masks either because of their fear
of the virus itself their completely
irrational fear
or their phobia you might say to use a
popular word
or because they don't want to be
associated with those terrible trump
supporters who weren't wearing masks
from the very
beginning so okay i'm glad i'm glad we
all agree that it's primarily
a symbol liberalism is very
very effective the liberal establishment
is
very very effective the one thing though
is that it's not
stable the liberalism
that we're seeing around us is of the
pull down the statues variety
so the revolution will always come for
its own and whoopi goldberg just pointed
this out
i'm not saying she actually just pointed
this out i'm saying there's a video
going around it sort of
surfaced of whoopi goldberg discussing
this problem of young liberals who are
who are just not happy with biden
they're saying it's not going far enough
and whoopi says hey wait a second we
come on we were the revolutionaries in
our day how come you're coming after us
now we did our part why are you so
ungrateful
look at what's happening with the
democrats you have two existing bodies
you got the new woke party
that movement and then you got the
establishment and they're eating each
other alive
they're you know what that's the truth
that is not so
it is not so stop listening to the media
who is leading you in a direction
that's what you're hearing the way they
talk about joe biden they're like i
cannot
stand the establishment i'm sorry that
might be the vp
but here's but here's the thing that you
that you're missing we've been doing all
that work that all these five-year-olds
say well y'all haven't been doing that
bull
what do you think how do you think
apartheid changed we did that
that's what joe biden did that's nobody
does
everything the way you want him to do it
but
do not put down the people whose
shoulders you're standing on
you are standing on our shoulders and we
are holding the line
and for people to say you're an honest
you uninspiring
what are you inspiring actually a very
conservative point
so whoopi goldberg says she's yelling at
some young lib
and she says how dare you say that we
aren't going fast enough or far enough
how dare you
you're standing on the shoulders of
people who are doing a lot of great work
how do you think apartheid ended we did
that so whoopi gold whoopi goldberg
identifies as ending apartheid
okay a british guy identifies as a
korean men identify as women and whoopi
goldberg identifies as
ending apartheid fine whatever
the point she's making is a very
conservative one it's one that i make
quite a lot
when i defend christopher columbus for
example or george washington
against ridiculous attacks i say how
dare you people you're standing on the
shoulders of giants these great men
who gave you your country and you think
that you're flying you spit on them
and that is what the left is doing and
whoopi says how dare you do that to us
well the problem of course is
conservatives you would hope would not
do that sort of thing conservatives have
a reverence for the past
they have gratitude they have humility
they feel a sense of obligation and they
feel quite at home in the democracy of
the dead the idea that
the past has something to say people
have gone before us
actually have something to contribute to
the present day
and we have something that we need to
bequeath on to
future generations and they ought to be
grateful to us
right we have this sense of continuity
but the left by definition doesn't have
that
the left is always trying to
revolutionize it's never good enough
because we're never really living in
utopia
so in order to to push forward the
revolution the past has always got to be
evil and depressive and enslaving
the present always has to be a crisis
and the future always has to be utopia
and now those those chickens are coming
home to roost whoopi
that's a problem it's that's the one
glimmer of hope that i do
have that the liberal regime no matter
how
much it's spying on tucker or going
after trump or going after conservatives
the one thing that does give me hope
here is it is unstable
it's just intrinsically unstable unlike
conservatism and so there are going to
be opportunities
every now and again to go in there and
give a little sucker punch to the system
and try to shape it a little bit more in
the direction that you would like
you're seeing this now with with trump
from the moment he left office the left
has been trying to throw this guy in
prison
lock him up lock him up that sort of
thing and
they took it very seriously i mean there
was never really a strong move to throw
hillary in prison trump had that good
line at the debate
where she said i don't want to live in
an america where trump is president he
said yeah because you'd be in jail
and everyone applauded and hooped and
hollered but no one ever took it
seriously there was never any actual
movement
to throw the clintons in prison namely
because they know their way around the
place pretty well you know they go in
and out jefferies in there they go in
take care of him
they john mcafee no i'm kidding
i'm kidding am i kidding i'm kidding
hillary please don't we're family don't
come after me
so there was never really a strong
movement to to throw hillary in prison
there was
a serious movement to throw trump in
prison i mean they're they're really
the the southern district of new york uh
various other places were looking into
charging trump with crimes and the
manhattan d.a
saivans just came out and said he does
not currently plan to charge
the trump organization with crimes
related to allegations of hush money
payments
and real estate value manipulations
according to a personal lawyer
for donald trump now just to begin
i don't think we should throw
ex-presidents in prison even if they
commit crimes by the way
i still don't think we should throw them
in prison
absent very very specific circumstances
i think that's banana republic kind of
stuff
increasingly we're living in a banana
republic so that's too bad
we're living in a banana republic where
the federal agencies spy on journalists
and where we can't even agree that that
men are not women and brits are not
koreans
but i'd like to stave that off as far as
we possibly can
want to maintain a somewhat civilized
system of politics trump blasted the
manhattan d.a
he said quote radical left new york city
and state prosecutors
who have let murderers rapists drug
dealers and all other forms of crime
skyrocket to record levels
and who have just announced that they
will be releasing hundreds of people
involved in violent crime back
under the streets without retribution of
any kind are rude
nasty and totally biased in the way
they're treating lawyers representatives
some of the wonderful long-term
employees and people within the trump
organization
after hundreds of subpoenas over three
million pages of documents four years of
searching dozens and dozens of
interviews
and millions of dollars of taxpayer
funds wasted they continue to be in
search of a crime
and will do anything to frighten people
into making up the stories or lies that
they want
they've been totally unable to get it in
an unprecedented move they retain an
outside never trumper lawyer from a
trump-hating law firm to work on the
case
it's a continuation of the greatest
witch hunt of all time this is true
no matter what you think of trump there
was a witch hunt they really did go
after him and they continued to go after
him and they continued to go after his
supporters
and they continue to go after people in
the media who who in
any way support the sort of thing that
he supports
this is really really bad stuff they say
that you can indict a ham sandwich right
and this is especially true
when there are many many many
complicated regulations and laws that
one could be violating at any given time
and so this is one of the arguments for
limiting
the scope of the government so that they
don't have
ways to entrap people for people to
commit crimes sometimes even
accidentally
and this is why there needs to be even
enforcement but right now there's not
even enforcement
if you loot on behalf of blm you get off
the hook and if you steal nancy pelosi's
elector and you go to prison for decades
absolutely outrageous speaking of bogus
crimes
right now justin trudeau the prime
minister of canada
looks a lot like fidel castro it's kind
of weird justin trudeau
demanded that pope francis fly to canada
to apologize on canadian soil
because they discovered some graves
at an old catholic children's school and
they were graves of
native of indigenous canadians
now i don't the story is so convoluted
it's so strange it was a school
for indian children and the
there were some graves and some of them
were not marked but they sort of had
been marked for a while but then i guess
they lost some of the markers
and anyway justin trudeau is demanding
that the pope apologize
this by the way as catholic churches are
being burned to the ground
two catholic churches two more catholic
churches on indigenous land
in british columbia's interior burned to
the ground on early saturday mornings
there's this big
struggle against the catholic church in
canada a huge suppression
of christians in canada i mean we've
we've played some of the videos on this
show
it really a real fear here that
christians are going to have to go
underground in canada like it was
communist china or something
the pope not that i'm telling the pope
what to do not that he's asked my
opinion but
he absolutely should not apologize this
is not about a serious
apology this is not about grace this is
not about this is about
a huge political attack on the church
which is what i think
all of this ultimately comes down to i
think all of these moves that we are
seeing
in the culture in our schools in our
politics in our
ultimately because all human conflict is
theological
it is an attack on truth and it's not
just political truth or cultural truth
it's all the way down
to religious truth which is why the
church always seems to bear the brunt of
this from the french revolution
up until the present everything
all aiming at that so what are we going
to stand for anything
are we just going to go along with it i
think those are the i think the options
are really that stroke
stand for something stand for objective
truth or
brits brits or koreans and football's
gay and kermit's a drag queen
and
every one of us is up to the whims of
the liberal regime whether we're tucker
carlson or donald trump
or just a regular old conservative i'm
michael knowles the michael knowles
shall see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadofsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 today on the
ben shapiro show california extends its
travel ban on state employees to red
states with 105 million american
citizens
when berry milks her anti-american
moment for all it's worth and the
supreme court decides to leave girls
unprotected in their locker rooms that's
today on the bench bureau shall give it
a listen